can I borrow someone's phone dud can I
just borrow a phone I'm just going to
show you something right so
um I'm just holding my phone while I'm
talking to you guys uh it's not buzzing
it's not beeping I'm not checking it I'm
just holding it let me just ask you a
question do you feel like you're the
most important thing to me right now
exactly there's a deep-seated
psychological reaction when you were
walking around a house with a client
holding your phone even if you're not
checking it and I have absolutely had it
where I've been walking around with an
agent and they're talking to me and then
I like look to the left and I turn
around and they're like
this guess how that made me feel